bella a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan di j
oggi siamo su the dead brauer
vabbè siamo sud e small orso iniziato
tipo da drogato ma non fateci caso per
il turismo nord sarebbe la custom map
che ho fatto nello scorso la scorsa
settimana per diventare ci sono dei
sequel e li farò tutti quanti perché
sono epici allora the small horse
faringei spacca di brutto sparagi st
custom e andiamo costa custom riesca a
la prima è divisa in capitoli tutti
penso allora non lo so ma visto il primo
credo che tutti siano così uno senso non
so come ecco perfetto siamo partiti già
è una cosa molto sensata
cos'è sta roba fin che la barca ma
[ __ ] allora ragazzone lo scopo di
sé va ancora non l'ho capito cos'è
questo è un osso perfetto è roba a
perfetto prezzo qualcosa e mi sapeva la
piazza porta di sicuro non chiedetemi
come un lato faccio ad aprire una porta
ma non ne ho idea
cos'è dove io vado dalla parte dove c'è
bianco va bene alla ragazzi se avete
visto tutti sono mi buongiorno salve io
io sto andando fuori
un giorno si tocca a stò perfetto non è
normale cos'è oddio uomini nudi che vi
seguono non sono che cazzo cazzo cazzo
via per bene i ragazzi non ha sempre
perfetto direi che abbiamo iniziato la
perfezione cosa ci sono i tool che
schifo cos'è
ci sono dei dei topi morti conigli per
cos'è sta che schifo
vabbè ci sono dei c'è un tappeto di topi
ragazzi perché sanno cos'è la con la
roba dal muro raga io gli ho più
giocassi così piume lincoln jackson
mezzo rincoglionito di mio ma più faccio
sta cosa e cosa è stato ancora nel
bianco ragazzi io stavolta vado dove
dove buio perché sono masochismo ok era
un [ __ ] porco state tranquille ok non
mi chiedete perché un maiale mi si è
materializzato davanti non voglio
neanche saperlo via sedia di merda cosa
c'è qua del fuoco chi è che ha dato
fuoco alla scrivania scusa ok l'olio mi
serve avrò dimenticato tipo la chiave
qui dietro da qualche parte non lo so la
ragazza ci sono dei ragni sul soffitto
cos'è sta roba
ci sono le ragni
fu soffitto cazzo cos'è cos'era quella
merda cos'è sta roba cose che mi compare
ogni 4 secondi perché ci sono dei ragni
sul soffitto e non è normale che cosa
cazzo cos'è cosa basso nel fuoco sesta
roba sì ma stai calmo che cosa cosa chi
è che ha gridato che vuole stuprarmi
ragazzi qualcuno ha gridato che vuole
stuprarmi io ho trovato una chiave bene
non mi interessa chi voleva stuprarmi i
nomi dei ragazzi siamo per essere
stuprati da un pony o cosa
perché c'è un pony dico sa cos'è
successo perché perché la mia sanità
mentale sta andando a bicchia cosa sta
succendo allora apriamo le porte perché
io non ci sto capendo fino a marzo mai
apri chiudi dietro che c'è qualcuno che
mi scusi cosa cosa sta scuse ragazzi
cosa io gli ho bisogno di un calmante
quando gioca ste cose non asse cosa ho
preso una spa un pugnale cos'è un pick
up perfetto l'ho trovato
non mi chiedete qual cosa è riuscito da
sta roba cos'è un cesso pubblico dai
ragazzi io esco ho capito perché tanto
non ha senso
lo sto continuando a dire non ora che sa
ma parlano senso ma se non l'avesse
capito ragazzi aspettate nomi e nel
termine non ha senso perfetto allora la
prima sta porta prima che
oddio oddio qui abbiamo gente
noi siamo adesso non lo so perché c'è
una porta sud è normale una porta sul
soffitto
cioè non è mai non ho mai giocato non
l'ho mai giocato la cos'è calmi
era un deposito di aden sciarini era un
debbo agenti una chiave perfetto che
iphone parte varazze ok
merda apriti o cioè ben chiuchiù digione
dove poté ragazze
non c'è qualcuno sul soffitto ragazzi
non mi interessa cosa c'è fretta
le rotte e tra veloce aiuto aiuto e tra
le cavità
ecco è successo
realizzati no kat
trasmetto questo non si smaterializza di
sai8 ok si smaterializzano
eni mit o cavaliere al contrario sta
diventando brutta faccenda aprile porta
ricorrenti caci perché c'è un pick up
sulla porta perché non lo voglio sapere
perché andiamo avanti cosa che si parla
perché è la stanza è sottosopra fatemi
capire cos'è vendite io non ho capito
che cos'è una borchia gol oltre a due
cose l'una strange vuole una poker per
vendola l'ha mai catturiamo al pikachu
che sta sulla porta perfetto ok ma mi
chiudere qui ci sono le legata ragazzi
mi ricorda il reporter sto pezzo mi
ricorda troppo e ricco cast fumare
comprendo la chiave a caso è dentro di
aprile e questo l'ha figata lei sa che
questa è veramente figlia come cosa io
io le prendo tutte [ __ ] ve la
facciamo così vai con te vai col come
quazzo sono genoa che poi non mi ricordo
poi li ho preso con ok perfetto con
trovata a cazzo che culo assurda caserta
stanza non credono alla giura ghazi io
io io mi sembra di andare in bocca ogni
volta che gioco si sta cazzo di custom
maps
mi sembra di aver bevuto due litri di
vodka o cose così
e quest'anno non so come sia questa
volta miss aqua dietro c'è qualcosa sì
c'è qualcuno non so permesso ragazzi
sfondando
e poi perché sto mandando di testa giuro
cos'è sto posto cosa c'è qui niente
perché c'è una porta ragazzi ho paura ho
paura seriamente ad andare avanti
sistema per perché ci sono duemila
cassetti non mi fatto aprire due
miliardi se va bè ciao devo trovare una
chiave qui dentro è come trovare il
nuovo di rosita nel mulino bianco
allora ragazzi se cos'è c'è un braccio
beh allora non so se può andar bene
ragazzi cosa devo fare qui
bene io ho una sedia qui perfetto da
ragazzi non è normale senti prendi la
mia sedia non lo no truffe su una sedia
tu non l'hai accettato quella che mi
offendo io io io sono veramente
esasperato ci sono dei porci ragazzi non
è normale giocava perché mi fate giocare
perché hai forza in un anno la gravità
perché sono cos'è dal mio dio porci
nello spazio ragazzi non ho io io voglio
finirlo archivio che sto andando di
cervello vi giuro
alla fine
[Musica]
raga catturiamo lo bastardo merda e mi
sa che non dovevo canto lame via via via
via via via via via via io penso
seriamente di perderci
non so quanta sanità mentale ma nella
realtà a giocare asta mappa ma vabbè
andiamo avanti senza farsi troppe
domande sono anche quasi morto non
importa ho veramente un brutto
presentimento qui va bene anch'io cielo
il brutto presentimento da quando siamo
partiti però governo entra un quinto e
cos'è cos'è sta roba ragazzi dove sto
cosa sto facendo
sembra la stanza di un boss di final
fantasy
ma capisco questo zio cos'è aiuto di
madrid per da verte verso soltanto nel
regno dei toni sono entrando nel regno
dei poli salvami chiunque tu sia chi sei
ok se ne sono andati buongiorno piacere
sì anche anch'io ma di parla a sky ha
tastiera jesi ma guarda le domeniche io
sono lì per lei la guardia pagina
facebook altrove descrizione come in
ogni mio mito
le schiacciate io sono ben ragazzi mi mi
ha sganciato un po unito è giusto fare
conoscenza con il podio rubicondi no non
mi dite che finisse così
li avete fatto scherno robe ragazzino da
temi che mario cos'è sta merda ma
cos'era corsera store o col casco mi fa
ad enzo caro ogni volta ceva e gli ma vi
rendete conto che io vado a dormire
sapendo di aver giocato sta roba ai
colorati che non è una cosa bella cioè
nel senso poi avete un senso di amarezza
perché poi il ragazzino lo farà anche la
parte pre lista roba perché vabbè io ha
concluso qui la ragazzi io io va bene
trevi dove è piaciuto ha lasciato
sgomento mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete a crisi
di iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bene ragazzi
[Musica]